[Music]
here you go
anything else I can do thank you what
happened to foreign theory Michael it's
okay two minutes is too soon for five
minutes and two minutes is a very big
difference money to pay the people who
sell us say it's under money I can't do
this
basically Michael oh hey
think again just for the record I think
I'm overreacting a little bit
your mom's old enough to make her own
decisions oh well thanks Oscar
I was just wondering how would you feel
if Michael was sleeping with your mom
my mother's in a wheelchair just for the
record oh I'm sorry it's late
my mother's in a wheelchair I had to
make a snap decision Dwight no you
didn't you were sitting there for an
hour it was a lot of snap decisions you
pop the trunk
why did you Michael this isn't my car
it's for the show property you're
looking at is in great shape and
equipment Christine
whoa whoa something major happened
wasn't my fault
installed poorly okay I know Bob Vance
Dwight Schrute I work next door just
give him a call call Bob Vance call Bob
Vance Bob I'll call you back
and we don't want them at our wedding
thinking Jim's being marched down the
aisle by my dad with a shotgun
well there's not gonna be a shotgun no
no shotgun that changes everything
can't back out now Albert what are you
gonna do about it
there's no shotgun it was so cute dusted
off an oldie you should see their baby
so I guess you recognized everybody else
you all right she's drunk Oh
[Laughter]
rain rain what sorry Wow you coming ring
oh whoa whoa Ellie I think we're out of
fax cover sheets whoo
shut it yep still breathing
Jim I said not till she's older okay
just a few of the pranks we have a plan
okay wait there it is it is rumored that
they will declare I can't can't see it
[Laughter]
David guess who I'm dressed up sorry
more time like I do I have the lines
right in front of me I know I've painted
them on the inside of my eyes Mosely you
don't have to do oh hey
so Jim thought of hey so Jim thought
yeah I'm happy because if Jim and Pam
can't yeah I'm thrilled because if Jim
and Pam can't be employee of the month
nobody can that's real fair I just got
out of the restroom
and it stinks the warehouse needs to go
okay wait how do you know it's the
warehouse who stunk up the bathroom
because they stink up the bathroom No
okay wait how do you know it's a
warehouse workers it stunk up the
bathroom they stink up the bathroom with
their smelly poof's gin oh they're gonna
turn on us come on
Kevin will be eaten Pam will be taken
slave Andy will be made a warlords
gesture and Meredith will do just fine
what can I do your skull will be what
can I do your skull will be made of soup
ball what can I do your skull will be
made of soup bowl what can I do
your sorry
what can I do your skull will be a soup
bowl cool it's hard to live this way I
don't know how you uh can you do it man
you gotta just just not care what people
think about you at all don't know how
you do it man I I can't be so cold your
baby you're not good I don't know how
you do it I don't know how you do it not
about the enjoyment is about well this
is all for Michael I'm sorry okay yeah
oh yeah okay all right rather than spend
the whole day in court we decided to
settle our dispute using a mediator it
was one of the options spelled out in
our child-rearing contract alleged
contract what are you talking about the
contract is alleged you wrote the
contract white your notarize was out of
date I used to be a cheater
tell us all love actually yeah what's
your point
here's my point here's the church here's
the steeple open it up there's all
people cheating on other people okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
hello wait shrewd Archie bar I'm sorry
Archie bar that's his name Dwight eat
spicy foods what is the opposite of that
make spicy foods come out of her okay
nope no eat spicy foods okay okay what
is the opposite of that takes spicy
foods come out of No okay
nope no we're not doing that Pam okay so
what is it eat spicy foods and the
opposite of that make spicy food
hey worker do you use the ladder or the
lift lift
we use that gift
are you crying Toby are you crying
you